[Music]
yeah in 2018 we made something that you
didn't like
so in 2019 we made a top-10 WatchMojo
video that will fix it oh [ __ ] donkey
oh here we go
back
[Music]
some women have said women upset
starting your business by selling
pirated songs oh hey
how do I go to bed I know we can you
Skype tonight but that's alright
goodnight girl I see you tomorrow
[Music]
but you don't have this blue but you
don't have this cream but you don't have
the biggest policy
[Music]
some guy in the front hey ninja do you
know Joe from fortnight I mean that was
one of the best questions I've ever been
asked Wow ha you were supposed to ask me
who Joe is marques Brown these cameras
are the main focus for the iPhone 11
throw
Oh
[Music]
I'm the bald guy brah me review who is
this guy mustn't want to be on a fence
or something I don't know who this guy
is
wait is that a real cool this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] this is all wrong today we will
be planting 20 million trees
[Music]
hello army dill extra hack here with
another pewdiepie update
[Music]
doing a fine job makes tough you're
proud of it
my message to you is to be strong no
matter what you're going through if
you're on a professional help seek help
being off surround yourself with people
that help you make sure that whatever
life that you want you'll just strive
for that [ __ ] you make sure you go for
that [ __ ] don't let anyone tell you it's
not possible don't let anyone tell you
that's not practical the drive you need
to get it you pull that from yourself
coz when you pull it from yourself no
one can influence it we must stop the
glorification of violence in our society
this includes the gruesome and grisly
video games
[Music]
but Stephen Christy oh man
okay so now he's cheated Wow meow
[Music]
I can't do this
Twitter you guys notice
of the year
[Applause]
but before we continue the video have
you heard that amazing free-to-play
MMORPG pvp via phone
it has over 5 million downloads and is
number one on the google question
[Music]
do you agree with our top 10 picks let
us know in the comments below and check
out all the creators in this video in
description can't wait to see what you
do next year YouTube good luck
[Music]